but i want it to end on hope and the
hope is that joe biden will not be
president forever right
he's old
the ideas aren't great
things are cyclical
good guys come around and win over time
and uh there's a great woman behind him
her name's kamala harris
see what i did there sorry about that
this is a poor ending
uh kamala two days ago right before the
state of the union uh here's her on a
radio show trying to explain to the
masses what's happening in russia and
tell me is this the woman who you want
one heartbeat away from the presidency
or someone who maybe maybe should be
teaching kindergartners but probably not
really if you're watching any level of
news even social media you're seeing
everything that's going on right now in
the ukraine break it down to layman's
terms for people who don't understand
what's going on and how can this
directly affect the people of the united
states so ukraine is a country in europe
it exists next to another country called
russia russia is a bigger country russia
is a powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so
basically that's wrong
lord help us
lord help us one heartbeat away from the
presidency i mean the woman has no
understanding of anything as i always
tell you she was polling at zero percent
in her own party
when the powers that be told joe to
select her
and she talks and
and conveys information
like a complete idiot like oh my
russia's big
ukraine's small that's bad you can't do
that
here's kamala also two days ago on
election outcomes and what are they
juicing her with with the shakes take a
look
because as we all know elections matter
and when folks vote they order what they
want and in this case they got what they
asked for
[Applause]
i went off script a little bit
remember when harry met sally i'll have
what she's having like i don't want
whatever she's having like what they've
whatever they've got her on they've got
biden on something they've got her on
something and she's constantly doing
this and she's shaking the arms and they
got what they wanted we did the election
and okay
[Laughter]
lordy lordy lordy